Hello everyone, welcome to Nutraceutical 101, today's topic is leaky gut.
What is leaky gut?
It is the lining of your small intestines that become damaged.
It allows toxic waste products to literally leak through the intestines and make its way
into the bloodstream.
This causes an autoimmune response in the body, and that results in inflammatory and allergic
reactions.
So the main sources of this reaction is gluten, soy, and dairy.
Those are going to be the high inflammatory foods.
The symptoms you may experience with leaky gut are any of those that are listed here.
So you just want to make sure that you are paying attention to what you are consuming in
any of these three categories, especially.
So how do you heal your gut?
Something that we use here at the clinic is sunspectrum.
This contains a pre and probiotic.
Everybody that I've talked to knows what a probiotic is, but the prebiotic is essentially
going to increase that good bacteria to assist the probiotic in working and healing the
gut.
So you can picture the probiotic sense of flowers and the prebiotic as the fertilizer to help
those flowers grow.
You can order sunspectrum at connoorsclinic.com if you need any assistance in healing your
gut.
Remember that you are in control.
The best part about leaky gut is you get to decide what it is you are consuming.
You'll either be feeding a disease or fighting it.
A leaky gut can contribute to a leaky brain and you will find that in the symptoms you
are experiencing.
So make sure that you are feeding yourself something that is going to also feed your mind.
If you have any questions, please check out our website at connoorsclinic.com.
Thank you.